wonderful show for you tonight coming to
you uh from the
uh theater here uh that's a wonderful
place to do a show
andy what's the name of the theater uh
largo
at the coronet yeah it seems like like
some shady tax deal
yeah like it does it's two names it's a
theater that has two names
yeah it's largo at the coronet which one
is it i don't know i think this whole
thing is a shame yeah yeah right why not
just call it fly by night
yeah yeah and there's a closed strip
club across the street
have you been there no neither have i no
it's closed there's a closed strip club
across the street from our theater and
right next to it is a covid testing
center and i think they i don't know if
they know that they spelled sin
incorrectly yes but it's a gentleman's
club yeah
and i've always wanted to belong to a
gentleman's club
you got to dress real fancy at those
places i know and learn how to speak all
proper but i want very much
to one day finish a show here across the
street with you my good friend andy
and go to sin gentlemen's club and then
when we're asked to leave at 3 a.m get a
covid test next door wouldn't that be
nice
that would be good let's make that
happen well excellent show tonight
uh one of my favorite people colin quinn
is on the program tonight
andy's with us and we've got a date to
go to sin
gentlemen's club yeah i'm going to wear
since you got to be fancy i'm going to
wear a monocle and every time i see a
pretty lady i'm going to
it's going to fall out
and then you put it some clues and then
you put another one
you put it back in the dress oh
have you seen the steam table
the buffet is fantastic i can't wait to
go
maybe we'll bring a camera and you'll
come with us oh right
that's not gonna happen